hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the match magnus carlsen versus
daniel luba from the opera euro rapid
knockouts
uh and this is quite the short one and
quite an exciting one so let's just dive
straight into it adobe had
some good chances in the previous game
so now he definitely needs to do
something
otherwise uh yeah it's just going to be
very hard as magnus already won the
first match so magnus now with the white
pieces
uh opens with e4 that's not an e pawn e4
e5 we have knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 now seeing if dubois is
maybe interested in some evan's gambit
action
uh but dubo says no thank you he goes
knight to f6 that goes for the two
knights defense and now
d3 uh we have h6 by above and now knight
to c3 and the bishop to b4
uh we have castles and dubois eliminates
the knight we have bishop captures b
captures and castles so he gives up the
bishop pair early but he
uh definitely has uh his reasons for it
uh and here there are a lot of possible
moves and a lot of moves have been
played in this position rook to e1 is
the known move bishop to eighth reason
will move
a lot of any move that basically
develops a piece or or you know
grabs more space is playable but magnus
goes for bishop to b3
it's a new move and it's a it's a
well a rather weird one uh so already as
of move eight we have a completely new
game yeah you cannot go
after the bishop because the e5 pawn is
still hanging so first
d6 noob of defense the e5 pawn and now
knights to d2 magnus uh says that he's
ready to start pushing the f pawn open
up the f file and
it's going to be a pretty wild game with
d5 by double
again uh just wasting a tempo he first
played d6 then played d5 but okay
uh e capture sunday five night captures
and now
knights to e4 as the square has been
vacated um
for the night and only now knight to a5
going after carlson's bishop so bishop
captures
magnus also gives up the bishop pair
queen captures in the now
now comes the movie that uh probably
should do both a little bit but magnus
played it pretty much instantly as
he definitely has this prepared bishop
captures on h6
and it seemed that it's not that do of
missed bishop captures an h6 the dubo
just
thought that f5 and what's the point of
bishop h6 i mean of course bishop cannot
be captured because knight of six chuck
loses the queen
but i i guess duba thought if i just
play f5 which he eventually did
uh what's the point of this idea now the
bishop is hanging and also the knight is
hanging but magnus instantly played c4
and he just said uh well there's uh a
couple of squares for a queen so where
are you going to retreat the queen
or are you maybe interested in capturing
the pawn here capturing on c4 is
definitely an option
but after knight captures you get knight
c3 attacking the queen and this knight
and only then after the queen moves
let's say you go after the knight can we
do some trades captures captures and
then uh queen d5
check and so on the game continues uh
but it's a very
uh it's it's a good position for both
black and white but i'm sure
magnus knows all the intricacies of the
position so he was very happy to go into
this
duval however went queen back to c6
instead
and now magnus goes back with the bishop
saying that okay you capture the knight
i captured this knight
uh dubo says okay with f captures on e4
bishop captures on a5 and now queen to
g6 now dubo
uh shifts the queen over to the attack
bishop h3 could be an idea going for
some checkmating ideas
and magnus goes queen to e2 develops the
queen
goes after the e4 pawn and you know
and so on bishop to h3 now wouldn't be
all that impressive because queen
captures an e4
offers a queen trade while also
defending against checkmate so here
after queen to e2 we have rook to f4 by
nubov adding another defender to the
pawn
and here uh magnus started to think a
little bit
and f3 is what you want to play here f3
is just a very nice move because after
captures and captures you can just trade
everything
and the white's position is perfectly
fine however after this rook to f4 move
magnus played bishop to d2 he uh shifted
the bishop back into the game with tempo
as the rook is under attack
but unfortunately for magnus dubo has an
even greater tempo so he plays bishop to
g4
now attacking carlson's queen on e2 and
there's not
a good square for the queen now if you
play queen to e1
uh bishop to f3 threatens checkmate and
there's not much to be done if g3
queen to g4 is coming and there's no
stopping checkmate even if you capture
the rook doesn't matter queen h3 and
you're getting checkmated
so after this bishop to g4 we have f3 by
magnus this is absolutely forced
and now bishop captures on f3 uh chasing
away the queen you still have to keep an
eye on the g2 pawn otherwise you're
still getting checkmated
so queen to f2 only move that prolongs
the game and
now comes rook to g4 absolutely
strongest move by duba
going after the g2 pawn so g3 again
forced and now rook to f8 and now all of
uh duval's pieces are
mobilized for the attack and the magnus
has a very few moves that
actually help him so he goes to rook 8
to e1
uh getting uh he's his last rook into
the game
and now rook to f6 by do both so what do
you play here
magnus goes d captures on e4 he sees no
no problem with this move and now comes
queen to h5 by do both now again
uh would you play here uh well there are
a couple of moves you could play but
magnus goes for the absolutely uh the
the most correct one and that is
rook to e3 he adds more pressure to the
bishop here
and now comes bishop captures on e4
opening up an attack towards carlson's
queen and
that's why the rook was lifted to f6 so
the pawn also defends it
uh and now you have to play queen to e1
after queen to e1 it's gonna be a
terrible game for white white is going
to suffer immensely but
the game will continue for quite a bit
longer
however here magnus played queen to e2
and
now dubo has a brilliant move that ends
the game on the spot
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for duboff
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen on e2 is undefended and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
the only winning move here is rook
captures on g3 with
check and uh after dove played this it
was in this position that magnus carlson
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you have to capture the rook it doesn't
matter what you capture it with or
rather it does if you capture with the
pawn it's queen to h1 checkmate so
uh that's not happening so you have to
capture with the rook and then just
queen captures an e2 and you have no
no counter play whatsoever it's just a
game over uh
there's nothing you can do here you
could capture here because the g pawn
cannot capture but just queen captures
on d2
and queen and bishop against two rooks
is is an a very easy win
uh so after this rook captures on g3 uh
magnus resigned and the double uh
increases his chances of getting back
into the match immensely as this is only
game two double already got a win so he
only needs
one more one more win to equalize for
losing uh
the first match so we'll see what
happens definitely exciting stuff
so hope you guys enjoyed that i'm sure
magnus magnus definitely didn't
i would like to thank enrico salami
tito reynaldo justin pollard and david
kimber for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day